les bébés lecteurs sont à l'honneur dans
le cadre de la Semaine babillage ils
sont en photo dans une exposition à
découvrir à la médiathèque du canal de
Montini le Bretonneux moi j'ai
photographié cette prise en main des des
enfants et cette découverte des des
premières lectures en essayant de me
faire tout petit tout petit tout petit
et en laissant les moments se dérouler
devant moi à l'endroit ou à l'envers
l'objet livre ne laisse pas indifférent
les bambins âgés de 12 à 27 mois c'est
ance quantau qui a mis en scène
l'exposition Les SEP thématiques
correspondent à l'évolution du
comportement des enfants lors de ces
séances de lecture qui se sont déroulé
en crèche
pour montrer aux adultes le regard que
pouvait avoir le petit par rapport à
l'album et à travers toutes les
expressions qu'il avait soit en
individuel quand il écoute une histoire
soit en collectivité des citations
d'ouvrage sur la littérature et les tout
petits viennent enrichir l'exposition et
j'ai trouvé des extraits de René dicting
marine Bonafé qui ont été vraiment
initiateur de la littérature et du
tout-ptit et puis aussi des regards de
croisés de bibliothécairees de parents
sur Ben comment fonctionne l'enfant avec
le livre et quelles sont toutes ses
émotions à travers la lecture les
émotions sont liées aux cinq sens c'est
ce que démontre une deuxème exposition
toc toc dans les livres en pleine
préparation ce matin à la médiathèque
Antoine de saint-exupéri de voisin le
Bretonneux des mobiles suspendus du
mobilier des tissu et des livres de
l'auteur et illustratrice jeunesse de
référence Jeanne HB que les enfants
puissent bouger sortir un un livre de
l'arbre là ce fruit là et l'adulte qui
est là le lise c'est euh le jeu n'est
qu'un prétexte en fait parce que c'est
exactement c'est la reproduction des
albums de Jean HP qui sont très simples
qui sont bien basés sur les cinq sens un
livre d'or est à disposition pour
laisser un mot à Jean HB l'auteur et
illustratrice sera aussi en conférence
ce Samedi avril à l'auditorium de trappe
et à la salle léop féré de montiny
lebretonneux